wir schauen aus dem fenster und sagen
auch heute ein sommer der keiner ist aus
deutscher sicht ist es nass und trüb
während bei uns ein tief nach dem
anderen für ich sag mal schlechte laune
sorgt sieht es anderswo ganz anders aus
in griechenland türkei italien grillt
die sonne den mensch das tier das land
das ist unser thema heute heftige brände
am mittelmeer und damit herzlich
willkommen bei heute live wie immer sind
wir an eurer meinung interessiert stellt
uns fragen gebt eure kommentare ab und
dieser adresse die und ein
eingeblendetes zdf heute - live at zdf
de wir werden natürlich auf eure
kommentare zu sprechen kommen wir
beginnen den griechenland- und da ist
mir jetzt zugeschaltet meine kollegin
meike srowig sie ist vom zdf sie ist und
das müssen wir kurz einmal erklären von
mit einem griechen verheiratet und fährt
jedes jahr mehrfach dorthin auch dieses
jahr wieder ihr wart in thessaloniki
maicon wenn wir uns das jetzt mal kurz
auf der karte anschauen dort seid ihr
gewesen und sei dann anschließend einmal
quer durchs land gefahren gestern noch
jetzt seid ihr auf der insel kefalonia
damit wir das verstehen da kommt es
jetzt gleich wo wir seit kefalonia damit
wir das zum einen verstehen deswegen wie
gesagt diese hinweise dass du sozusagen
aufgrund deines mannes der familiäre
bindung hast und das land wirklich gut
kennst aber eben auch aufgrund der
erlebnisse von dieser fahrt gestern
einmal quer durchs land wie war's jetzt
nichts gesehen aber auch nicht weiter
verwunderlich weil das wie sehr weit von
der autobahn entfernt ist allerdings
muss man sagen das ist natürlich hier
ein dauerthema griechenland mit den
waldbränden und wir wissen davon alle
und sehen das natürlich auch die ganze
zeit in den nachrichten verfolgen und
[Musik]
die griechen sind das allerdings gewohnt
das ist keine außergewöhnliche situation
mit weiteren umzug in allerdings ist
dieser sommer schon besonders weil diese
hitze eben sehr lange anhält bereits an
mehreren tagen
es gab auch die warnung dazu und die
neuesten informationen sind auch dass es
inzwischen sehr viele auch kleinere
waldbrände gibt es wenn man gar nicht
bescheid weiß jetzt wo
ganz wie die großen waldbrände über die
alle gerade derzeit berichten
binnen 24 stunden ist zu lesen 92
waldbrände nochmal hinzugekommen jetzt
sind die griechen waldbrände und hitze
insgesamt gewohnt auch du hast den
vergleich aber was ist anders in diesem
jahr also zum einen muss man jetzt
wirklich sagen dass das ist auch die
diskussionen hier in erster gewickelt es
darum die menschen zu retten und auch zu
evakuieren
das hängt damit zusammen westlichen land
vor zwei jahren ja eine große feier ins
ferne hat in der nähe von athen wo sehr
viele menschen auch bereit gestorben
sind die jagd sicherlich die bilder noch
im kopf von damals und das ist etwas was
den griechen ganz starken kopf ist woran
sie auch jetzt denken vor allem wenn die
feuer so nationen wieder dran sind
es gibt auch inzwischen natürlich außer
den inzwischen die gerichte dass
möglicherweise der strom abgeschaltet
werden muss weil das feuer doch nicht
richtig unter kontrolle bringen können
was diese rauchschwaden in die stadt
rein ziehen
das ist etwas was mich ungewöhnlich ist
auch allerdings ist das so dass athen
sowieso zu dieser jahreszeit wer kann
bleibt nicht er geht aus der stadt raus
weil ich eben schon so heiß ist und wenn
jetzt diese rauchschwaden ihnen noch mit
dazu kommen dann verursacht es natürlich
noch besondere situation gerade für
ältere menschen
wir haben selber meiner schwiegermutter
jetzt gerade gestern wir tatsächlich
noch jede menge wasser gekauft und die
ihre lebensmittel aber wieder aufgefüllt
dass sie hatte überhaupt nicht raus muss
bei der hitze war wie sie selber zu mir
neulich gesagt hat michael ist es ja in
foren hob es ist wie ein backofen wenn
ich die tür aufmache und das ist
tatsächlich die situation überall im
land und gerät ja auch dadurch den
bildern die ihr zeigt was ein bisschen
was man glaube ich zum teil nicht
richtig weiß ist dass sie griechenland
60 prozent der fläche des landes gebirge
ist und damit auch weit und das ist
natürlich etwas was in der
augenblicklichen situation sich schnell
entzünden kann der reicht eine
glasscherbe aus und wovor die griechen
jetzt vor allem angst haben ist dass es
angeblich ab morgen wind zu nehmen soll
und das wäre natürlich eine schlimme
situation weil das natürlich noch dass
die situation schlimmer machen wird die
im weitgehend unter kontrolle zu
bekommen
dem erst mal der reihe nach durch wir
haben wie wir sehen auch da oben bei dir
die datenrate ziemlich niedrig aber
deinen ton kommt gut an es ist immer
wieder mal dass das bild stehen bleibt
wir sehen ja die bilder aus griechenland
weil man noch mal bei dem thema backofen
was du da gerade geschildert hast was
aus der familie so gesagt wird wie hält
man das ausklammern kann wasser kaufmann
kann viel trinken
aber das allein reicht ja nicht ist das
land gelähmt gewesen
wir sind natürlich inzwischen so das
doch sehr viele leute im klimaanlagen
haben mit den autoren haben gelaufen
natürlich alle auf hochtouren
was natürlich jetzt wenn es dazu kommen
sollte dass der strom zum teil
abgeschaltet werden muss sind in athen
natürlich auch noch massive auswirkungen
haben wird
es gibt inzwischen hat man zumindest das
alles vorbereitet ist dass es wie
sowieso hallen gibt leute die eben kein
mediator haar und eine klimaanlage haben
wo die daneben hingehen können wo es
gefühlt ist aber man kann natürlich
tatsächlich nicht viel machen also ich
sag das jetzt mal aus sicht von
touristen okay da geht hat und wie geht
man halt an strand oder irgendwie und
das eben später
aber die leute hier ist das natürlich
schon etwas was wahnsinnig lange anhält
was im visier wo man irgendwie auch
nicht das normale tägliche leben
weiterführen kann
ich habe das selber erlebt internet
sondern wie geht da gibt es ein großes
shoppingcenter haben sich viele hin
geflüchtet wenn wir in den vergangenen
tagen war natürlich alles thematisiert
ist dort aber das ist natürlich
irgendwie auch nicht so eine richtige
ausweisen wirklichkeit auf dauer was die
lage in athen angesprochen gucken wir
ein bisschen weiter nördlich auf dem
berühmten ort und ja auch in diesen
zeiten gerade wo die olympischen spiele
laufen nach olympia dort ist die lage
auch dramatisch und der zuständige
katastrophenschutzminister sagt wir
kämpfen gegen titanen schauen wir uns
auch da ein paar bilder an die aktuell
sind zum einen aus der nacht aber eben
auch von heute ja seit mittwoch
versuchen jetzt die feuerwehren dort in
einem gewaltigen kraftakt muss man sagen
die brandherde rund um das antike
olympia unter kontrolle zu bringen
zuletzt heißt es gelang es jetzt das
feuer einzudämmen zumindest kurz bevor
die flammen das unesco-welterbe
erreichen
die städte ist vorerst gerettet heißt es
vom gouverneur aber die gefahr ist nicht
vorbei worauf richten sich die menschen
einen du hast vorhin schon mal gesagt
winde werden jetzt noch erwartet das
kommt dann noch hinzu kann man sich
tatsächlich darauf
bereiten oder das sind die gefühle die
die menschen jetzt haben ist es nur
angst ist es sorge oder was treibt die
menschen gerade ich kenne es eigentlich
von jedem sommer so dass man damit
rechnen muss nur im augenblick ist die
gefahr als sehr groß
man sieht dass wenn man rausgeht ihr vor
die tür ist so trocken
da reicht ein funke aus und wir das ist
total nachvollziehbar und man muss
natürlich auch sagen griechenland ist
auf diese waldbrände vorbereitet es gibt
die es gibt die flugzeuge man hat jetzt
auch gerade wieder mehr flugzeuge
angefordert allerdings ist das land
natürlich dann schon mit der situation
überfordert wenn es an so vielen
unterschiedlichen orten gleichzeitig
passiert das ist auch für die griechen
die waldbrände gewohnt sind die schon
auch in einer gewissen art und weise
darauf vorbereitet sind dann doch eine
außergewöhnliche situation ich glaube
nicht dass das wenn das jetzt die
nächsten tage noch so anhalten wird und
tatsächlich diese brände sich weiter
entfachen sollten und auch weiter geben
sollten
das ohne hilfe aus dem ausland in
irgendeiner art und weise in griff zu
bekommen wird das glaube ich nicht wie
gesagt die griechen haben ein trauma von
vor zwei jahren als das in dem matthias
irrt es in dem vorort von athen als über
100 menschen dabei gestorben sind
und das ist tatsächlich im augenblick
die hauptgeschichte zu gucken dass keine
menschen zu schaden kommen
evakuierungen gibt es derzeit viele
das wird auch weiter sein sobald eben
mehr orte davon betroffen sind weil es
gar keine andere möglichkeit gibt weil
sie die leute zu stützen habe gut ist
leider dann immer schwierig abschließend
noch wenn wir mal überlegen was es ja
auch mit den menschen macht wenn man
diese bilder sieht ist es so dass die
griechen auch verfolgt haben was hier in
deutschland geschehen ist die andere
seite der medaille die
hochwasserkatastrophe und stellst du
fest dass es eine eine veränderung im
bewusstsein gibt auf jeden fall so schön
das ist wir denn jetzt gerade gefragt
von vielen freunden wie geht es euch
seid ihr betroffen als die hochwasser
katastrophe gewesen ist
das umgekehrt dass viele griechen
nachgefragt haben und wir sagen ihr seid
ihr betroffen wie geht es den leuten vor
ort was das bewusstsein angeht etwas
klimawandel angeht und ähnliches ist das
hier natürlich schon noch mal eine
andere situation wir sind hier gerade
mit freunden aus deutschland und ich
habe mich gar nicht meine freundin
unterhalten die seite mein gott könne
nämlich endlich mal aufhören diese
plastikflaschen immer zu benutzen
es gibt so viele andere sachen wo man
sagen muss und wie auch da konnte man
schon etwas verändern und abkassiert
jetzt einfach nicht so viel
das hängt aber allerdings auch natürlich
immer auch mit der situation zusammen
das land hat eine wirtschaftskrise
wieder alle wissen hinter sich hier ist
eine andere geschichte und in ein
bewusstsein dauert glaube ich noch
einmal länger andererseits ist es auch
so dass man schon sieht dass die
griechen sehr viel in erneuerbare
energien investieren und auch versuchen
das weiter zu machen dazu gibt es auch
programmlich land machte ja auch ehrlich
gesagt sind in der situation ja mit der
sonne dass man irgendwie darf das buch
den strom in zukunft herr zu ziehen aber
das alleine wird nicht reichen
mein beruf ich danke für diese
schilderung aus griechenland guten
urlaub möchte man eigentlich wünschen
aber natürlich ist es etwas was wirklich
wie dieser rauch über dem land denke
aber trotzdem dass du dir die zeit
genommen hast danke und wir schauen
jetzt auf die türkei oder nicht nur in
der türkei sondern wirklich auf die
türkei denn wir haben hier ein paar
bilder vorbereitet die die nasa
veröffentlicht hat und da kann man sehr
gut sehen wie sich der rauch von den
bränden übers mittelmeer verteilt die
bilder stammen vom 29 juli bis zum
ersten august
und sie lassen erahnen welches ausmaß
das annimmt
und tatsächlich dass man diese
rauchschwaden bis weit in den weltraum
sehen kann und wie weit sie sich über
das mittelmeer hinweg gezogen haben wir
sprechen gleich mit unserem
korrespondenten lück wahl bot wollen
aber vorher noch ein paar stimmen und
meinungen aus der türkei ihnen zeigen
damit wir wissen wie dort die stimmung
ist natürlich sind alle besorgt etwas
und haben ein bisschen panik aber
wie gesagt wir uns vorher informiert es
gab keine probleme vorher und dann sind
wir einfach hergekommen das vorhaben die
andere seite von bodrum und
wir haben keine angst so alles gut
als wir zurück zum camp sind haben wir
gesehen wie das feuer sich dem
kohlekraftwerk genähert hat also haben
wir unsere sachen in die hand genommen
und sind zurück die leute hatten panik
[Musik]
ich habe keine erwartungen bin ich werde
die wälder die neu gepflanzt werden
sowieso nicht mehr sehen
vielleicht werden meine kinder das nicht
mal mehr erleben die geschichte unserer
vorfahren ist verbrannt meine kindheit
ist verbrannt und die zukunft unserer
kinder und die unsere enkel auch aber
aus irgendeinem grund hört uns niemand
aus istanbul wir haben es gerade gehört
haben urlauber die sind relativ
entspannt zumindest die wir dort gehört
haben aber die anwohner die sind schon
sehr aufgebracht wie viel wut im land
eine ganze menge nicht nur an der küste
übrigens in den betroffenen gebieten wo
immer noch zur stunde auch sieben brände
mindestens größere feuer wüten und nicht
unter kontrolle sind von insgesamt über
180 viele davon allerdings gelöscht
sondern der unmut breitet sich schon im
ganzen land aus das hat damit zu tun
dass man der regierung vorwirft nur sehr
schlecht auf diese brandkatastrophe
vorbereitet gewesen zu sein und auch
viel zu schleppend reagiert hat im kern
geht es dabei vor allem um
löschflugzeuge
es gibt eine flotte von sehr sehr
veralteten löschflugzeugen hier in der
türkei
die wurden schlecht gewartet oder gar
nicht gewartet weil das einem privaten
verein obliegt also das ist keine
regierungsorganisation sondern eine
private organisation die diese flugzeuge
unterhält und die waren schlichtweg
nicht einsatzbereit das heißt man musste
massiv im ausland um hilfe bitten sind
maschinen aus der ukraine da aus
russland aus der europäischen union aus
kroatien und spanien
selbst ein helikopter aus georgien aus
dem kleinen nachbarland der türkei
und das hat für enormen unmut in der
bevölkerung gesorgt weil man sagt für
vieles hat dieser präsident geld unter
anderem für einen riesigen kanal den er
bauen will hier in istanbul die
regierung unterhält selbst eine jet
flotte also regierungsflugzeuge
16 stück an der zahl der präsident
selbst hat zwei große boeing maschinen
aber offenbar reicht es nicht um ein
paar flugzeuge zu warten also da ist der
unmut sehr groß gehen wir gleich noch
genauer darauf ein bleiben noch kurz in
der situation bei der situation allein
im juli wurden 12.000 häuser evakuiert
36.000 menschen
das hat ja auch eine größenordnung wie
wirkt das auf die bevölkerung ja das
wird natürlich nicht gut das ist klar da
muss man sagen es ist sommer saison wir
haben es gerade auch aus griechenland
gehört hier in ganz ganzen
mittelmeerraum weiß man im sommer gibt
es leider waldbrände aber dieses ausmaß
hat die türkische bevölkerung
schlichtweg total überrascht man war
darauf gar nicht eingestellt
das sind knapp 100000 hektar land
waldfläche und olivenhaine die hier
verbrannt sind das ist sieben bis acht
mal so viel wie sonst in einem sommer
und darauf war man überhaupt nicht
vorbereitet
auch nicht auf diese evakuierungen von
so zahlreichen dörfern muss man sagen
die provinz mugla ist jetzt kein kleiner
landstrich das sind schon von der einen
ecke bis zur anderen 120 kilometer
unwegsames gelände hinter der küste dass
es hügeliges berggelände aber trotzdem
das ist natürlich verheerend und man
fragt sich warum waren die behörden
darauf nicht eingestellt du hast es
schon angesprochen
es gibt viel unmut aber eben auch die
rolle der regierung unter dem hashtag
help turkey gibt es einen aufruf zur
internationalen hilfe jetzt aber
ermittelt die türkische
generalstaatsanwaltschaft die
anscheinend partout das bild vermitteln
will
alles im griff zu haben warum ja zum
einen ist es mit der unabhängigkeit der
justiz hier in diesem land nicht weit
her
insofern darf man annehmen dass die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt weil von
oben ein dezenter hinweis kam zu
ermitteln das ist eben das politikum an
dieser affäre erdogan und seine
regierung fühlen sich hier extrem
schlecht dargestellt ganz einfach weil
sie auf dem kalten fuß erwischt wurden
und weil sie einfach schlecht
vorbereitet waren ich habe gerade das
problem der löschflugzeuge angesprochen
die menschen sind sauer und die
regierung möchte das so nicht
dargestellt haben weder von den
heimischen medien die hat man weitgehend
unter kontrolle
da kann man das abdichten aber auch
nicht bei internationalen medien und
dieser aufruf der ja von türkischen
bürgern kam im netz ans ausland bitte
helft wir haben hier ein problem dass
wir selber nicht lösen können das
widerspricht natürlich dem selbstbildnis
dass erdogan und seine regierung gelber
selber gerne von ihrer großen türkei
entwerfen der starken
wirtschaftsnationen die alles selbst
kann und auf keine fremde hilfe
angewiesen ist und das nervt natürlich
die regierung ist richtig geladen über
diesen hashtag und über die wut der
bevölkerung und da hat man offenbar die
staatsanwaltschaft jetzt in die spur
gesetzt was die sache aber nicht besser
macht denn das ist ja klar dass die
bevölkerung weiß woher die schuldigen
sitzen
wir haben hier gerade die bilder als
erdogan in der region war da werden
teebeutel tatsächlich verteilt er hat
sich ein bild vor ort gemacht warum
teebeutel vielleicht dass du uns das
auch noch mal erklärt und wie kam diese
geste an
ja das ist auch ein ja ein mittleres
kommunikationsdesaster dieser regierung
muss man sagen wir hatten ja muss man
vorsichtig sein bei uns in der
flutkatastrophe auch den einen oder
anderen aussetzer eines politikers den
ich hier nicht kommentieren will aber
erdogan ist da in seiner üblichen
wahlkampf muster verfallen muss man
einfach sagen
der mann ist der praktischen der
wahlkampf dauerschleife seit 20 jahren
in präsidentschaft regierungschef
verhallen kommunalwahlen landeswahlen
und diese geste t zu schmeißen also
geschenke an das wahl volk zu verteilen
bei diesen großen release also bei den
wahlkampfauftritten das ist so ein
geübter vorgang und irgendwie muss ihnen
da sein berater wohl abhanden gekommen
sein der ihm gesagt hat das ist in
dieser situation kommt nicht wirklich
gut an er hat einfach das wiederholt bei
sonst auch bei wahlkampf touren macht
und das fand die bevölkerung natürlich
extrem und passend statt mitgefühl mit
den betroffenen t in die menge zu werfen
das war jetzt nicht so dass was die
türken sich in dieser situation von
ihrem präsidenten erwartet haben und er
macht es auch zum instrument in dem er
anderen die schuld gibt da hat er mal
gesagt die kurden sind schuld jetzt gibt
ja der opposition die schuld also ist
das auch ein einfaches muster dass er da
wieder versucht und wie kommt das
wiederum an naja man muss sagen das land
ist ja praktisch tief gespalten
bei seinen anhängern kommt das gut an
obwohl das natürlich hanebüchen ist er
also praktisch behauptet der präsident
jetzt also die staatsregierung die
nationale zentralregierung ist
eigentlich nur für den schutz der welt
dazu ständig was da in den dörfern und
städten passiert dafür sind natürlich
die bürgermeister zuständig warum sagt
ja dass für für ausländische und klingt
das schräg er sagt dass weil in dieser
region insbesondere im bereich bodrum
das sind alles oppositionshochburgen
diese gemeinde dörfer städten dort sind
zumeist von der oppositionellen
sozialdemokratischen chp kontrolliert
und das heißt er nutzt das
innenpolitisch jetzt für einen aufschlag
aber auch das kommt selbst die eigenen
anhänger nur bedingt an man sieht ja
welches ausmaß diese katastrophe hat
hier in den medien wird ja auch über
über die brände in italien und in
griechenland in bulgarien berichtet und
dann zu sagen beispielsweise die linke
kurdische terrororganisation pkk sei
verantwortlich für die brände das ringt
selbst erdogan anhängern wirklich ein
sehr mildes lächeln hat glück wer bauen
mann noch gerade an dieser stelle 2
kommentare mit ein die ich dann auch
gerne an sich weiter erreichen möchte
das eine ist von thierry via youtube der
fragte wie bei die eu da helfen kann mit
löschflugzeugen du hast vorhin schon
einige beispiele genannt gekommen sind
und ob auch deutschland in dieser
hinsicht helfen kann ist das auch
gewollt würde ich da mal noch weiter
reichen und die zweite frage von ismail
04 auch via youtube
ob der politik denn der türkei der
klimawandel und die dürre und mehr
bewusst werden und wie gefährlich diese
welt brände für die regierung in athen
aber jetzt in diesem falle in ankara
tatsächlich werden können fangen wir mal
mit der ersten frage gar nicht habe das
gesagt die eu hat gleich am letzten
wochenende schon reagiert brüssel hat
herumgefragt bei den mitgliedstaaten und
wie gesagt das sind zwei spanische
löschflugzeuge eingetroffen die sind
schon seit drei tagen hier im einsatz
und auch maschinen aus kroatien ob da
mehr nötig ist das hängt vom türkischen
außenministerium ab die müssen die
anfrage stellen
aber die eu ist sicher bereit und auch
in
der lage zu helfen möglicherweise auch
deutsche maschinen bislang ist mir nicht
bekannt dass deutsche maschine angefragt
wurden oder im einsatz sind
das zweite ist eine wirklich
interessante frage denn umweltschützer
hier un experten beklagen seit langem
dass die türkische regierung und damit
ist natürlich erdogan gemeint der
praktisch das land seit 20 jahren führt
viel zu wenig bis gar nichts tut
für den klimaschutz ganz im gegenteil es
werden hier riesige eingriffe in die
natur vorgenommen die nicht dazu angetan
sind beispielsweise riesige
wasserkraftwerke die also der flussläufe
verändern
die nicht dazu angetan sind den
klimawandel zu stoppen bzw
das co2 ziel zu verbessern dazu gehört
auch die riesige mengen an plastik die
hier verbraucht werden
die jetzt beispielsweise wenn wir hier
in die region schauen die betroffen ist
die mangelnde landschaftspflege es gab
da viel zu wenig schneisen sogenannte
feuer schneisen die in den wäldern wie
man sie aus den alpen kennt also was
dann verhindert dass das feuer von einem
walter auf den nächsten übergreift alles
das gibt es nicht also klimawandel ist
überhaupt keine priorität hier für diese
regierung und das macht sich natürlich
irgendwann auch bemerkbar
letzte frage gibt es eine möglichkeit
oder siehst du sie das sozusagen durch
einen gezielteren tourismus dass leute
die sagen das möchte ich nicht mehr oder
da bin ich vorsichtig da fahre ich
vielleicht auch nicht mehr hin in dieser
form dass das einen druck ausüben kann
oder kommen die leute so oder so weil
die sonne scheint also das sind zwei
ganz unterschiedliche fragen fangen wir
mit der letzten an ich glaube und das
ist meine erfahrung nach einigen jahren
hier in diesem land dass die leute
sowieso kommen
es sind oft auch touristen mit einem
türkischen migrationshintergrund aber
eben nicht nur wie gesagt wir haben
heute auch am strand holländer getroffen
das sind briten
da und das ist relativ eindeutig da geht
es meist über das angebot und den preis
die türkei hat super strände hat super
touristische angebote ist meist
günstiger als viele andere europäischen
destinationen
das schafft einen anreiz das heißt
touristen kommen könnte man dadurch
druck ausüben auf die regierung ja
selbstverständlich
der russische präsident putin macht das
vor
er hat als hier erdogan den ukrainischen
präsidenten zielinski hier empfangen hat
sofort reagiert und alle urlaubsflüge
aus moskau und aus anderen russischen
städten in die türkei gestoppt und das
waren im letzten jahr knapp drei
millionen russische touristen hier und
das tut richtig weh
also ja man kann das einsetzen aber die
frage ist wer soll das steuern
wir können ja bei uns in einem
demokratisch verfassten land nicht
einfach einem tour operator oder einem
großen reiseanbieter sagen so jetzt
fliegt er mal nicht mehr in die türkei
also so einfach ist es nicht das zu
steuern
aber im prinzip gilt ja das ist eine
achillesferse des der regierung hier sie
brauchen die touristischen einnahmen und
da könnte man druck ausüben ja danke
lück und ich glaube der satz ist wichtig
zu sagen jeder urlauber oder jede
urlauberinnen könnte das steuern und
insofern sind das wichtige informationen
danke für diese einschätzung nach
istanbul glück war ja nicht nur in
griechenland und in der türkei brennt es
auch in italien sizilien kalabrien gibt
es schwere brände auch in bulgarien und
deswegen wollen wir uns noch mal ein
bild machen und insgesamt mal drüber
nach schon was muss jetzt getan werden
denn es geht nicht darum jetzt nur ein
einzelnes feuer zu löschen
das sind mehr fragen und die kommen
jetzt auch hier von euch die dargestellt
werden müssen und deswegen möchte ich
jetzt dazu schalten und bitten johann
georg goldammer guten abend sie sind
leiter des zentrums für globale feuer
überwachung und sind zugeschaltet aus
freiburg genannt schönen guten abend
feuer und waldbrände werbens gesehen
sind ja im prinzip nicht neu aber dieses
geballte auftreten derzeit muster sorge
machen
ja natürlich was ja angeklungen ist in
den kommentaren aus griechenland und
jetzt auch aus der türkei
es tun sich ja erhebliche veränderungen
unserer umwelt die sind bedingt einmal
durch den klimawandel
diese langanhaltenden extrem trockenen
wetterlage sehr stark beeinflusst durch
die injektion von trockener und heißer
luft aus der sahara nach süd osteuropa
in die türkei
es sind aber noch andere dinge die hier
eine rolle spielen nämlich die
landnutzung auch das ist eben schon in
kürze angesprochen worden und die
veränderung der landnutzung
einschließlich auch der
aufforstungsprogramme die erhöhen
tatsächlich das risiko von solchen
verheerenden bränden wie wir sie gerade
zwischen italien griechenland dem balkan
dem westbalkan und der türkei sehen
wollen wir das sortieren fangen wir
nochmal an also was ist derzeit das
eigentliche problem sind es zu viele
brände oder sind es zu viele brände die
gleichzeitig passieren
na ja es ist tatsächlich so dass wir
sowohl in der türkei als auch in
griechenland und besonders auch in
italien sehen dass sehr viele feuer
gleichzeitig brennen
in italien waren es ja an einem tag der
höhepunkt über 260 feuer
die gleichzeitig branden und da sind die
länder die im grundsatz schon recht gut
aufgestellt sind bei der
waldbrandbekämpfung und die italiener
sind das mit sehr kompetenten
einsatzkräften und den flugzeug staffeln
die sind in solchen momenten total
überfordert und um hier auch dann noch
mal auf die rolle der hilfeleistung aus
dem ausland zu sprechen
die europäische union das zivilschutz
verfahren der europäischen union hier
sind ja auch grenzen gesetzt weil es
eben in der union selbst auch brennt in
italien in griechenland in bulgarien wir
hatten brände in albanien nord
mazedonien und da sind halt die kräfte
gebunden die jetzt nicht unbedingt zur
verfügung stehen in das benachbarte
ausland
also das ist ein ganz großes problem
dass wir eben diese gleichzeitigen
brände haben die vielen brände und dazu
kommen daneben noch die gestiegene
anfälligkeit der natur und
kulturlandschaften in denen sich jetzt
zu diesen sommermonaten eben auch vor
allen dingen die touristen bewegen die
ja normalerweise in diesem land nicht
leben und die zu diesen zeiten die
regionen beleben und auffüllen so zu
sagen wo es jetzt brennt und das birgt
einige risiken
wollen wir mal kurz mal auch die
kommentare da hingehen dem
mittelmeerraum verlassen und auch mal
schauen wir sonst auf der welt los ist
in dieser hinsicht denn die frage von
thierry auch via youtube ist was da
zurzeit in südosteuropa passiert ist das
vergleichbar mit der dauer hitze in
kanada oder eben kalifornien hat das was
mit dem jetstream zu tun ist das alles
ein phänomen
ja das können wir so bestätigen diese
beobachtung diese langanhaltenden oder
wie wir sagen persistenten wetterlagen
die uns beispielsweise in deutschland ja
viele wochen und monate mit reichlich
niederschlägen und auch kühler polarluft
versorgt haben
die sorgen halt woanders dafür dass
diese lang anhaltenden trockenen
trocknen wetterlagen verbunden auch mit
hitzewellen nicht nur kanada betroffen
haben wir haben ja auch kürzlich
waldbrände in finnland gehabt die doch
auch einen großen umfang erreicht haben
und vor allen dingen sehen wir ja seit
einigen wochen schon seit dem
ausgehenden frühjahr in zentralasien das
heißt in sibirien in jakutien die brände
die vergleichsweise lange anhalten und
größenordnungen annehmen die doch schon
zu besorgnis anlass geben
kommen wir zurück zum mittelmeerraum
aber eben auch bei uns ist ja wie gesagt
alles zwei seiten einer medaille
so wie man beim hochwasser die deiche
nicht beliebig höher bauen kann so kann
man ja auch hier wahrscheinlich sich
nicht einfach schützen indem man mehr
löschflugzeuge kauft was muss passieren
wir sehen dass unsere kultur und die
naturlandschaften gerade hier in europa
sich sehr stark verändern und im grunde
genommen anfälliger gegenüber feuer
werden und woran liegt das
in der türkei in griechenland in italien
auf dem balkan setzt sich unverändert
der trend fort der landflucht der
verstädterung vor allen dingen der
jungen bevölkerung die die
landwirtschaft aufgeben nicht mehr die
betriebe der eltern übernehmen sondern
ihre berufliche zukunft in der stadt
suchen und das bedeutet dass viele orte
in den ländlichen regionen vergreisen
über altern wir finden nur noch die alte
generation und was vor allen dingen der
fall ist die intensität der
traditionellen landnutzung in der
landwirtschaft in der weidewirtschaft in
der bewirtschaftung von olivenhainen
oder auch wenn wir nach nordafrika
schauen in der bewirtschaftung von
korkeichen bildern
das führt dazu dass dieses nachlassen
diese intensiven kultivierung der
landschaften dazu führt dass alles was
nachwächst was an ökologischer
sukzession sich in richtung russland und
magna entwickelt nun sehr viel mehr
brennbar ist als diese alten
kulturlandschaften in der im grunde
genommen
durch die intensive nutzung dem feuer
alles brennmaterial entzogen wurde und
wenn wir sollten uns zusammen sagt sie
da richtig verstehen und damit wir sie
da sogar ein bisschen mitnehmen also es
geht darum dass wie sie sagen landflucht
stattfindet dass die menschen sich nicht
mehr in dem maße wie früher um ihren
land gekümmert haben das land sozusagen
nicht mehr so bewirtschaftet wird wie
bisher anfälliger dafür wird zu solche
feuer
das ist richtig so und dann tritt dann
in einigen ländern sogar an die stelle
und das können wir auch in der türkei
sehen weil es dort in aufforstung brennt
das in der türkei aber durchaus auch auf
der iberischen halbinsel
anstelle der alten land nutzungsform nun
plantagen mit schnell wachsenden
baumarten aufgeforstet werden das sind
das sind kiefern arten und wir sehen
gerade in der türkei dass dieser
aufforstung brennen und das sind ja
aufforstungs plantagen und ökosysteme
wie sie von natur aus nicht da waren und
die brennen besonders heftig und
besonders großflächig und hier entsteht
praktisch durch diese neue form der
land- oder waldbewirtschaftung entsteht
auch ein neues risiko und das kommt
alles zusammen
das kann man natürlich sehen sie dass
die leute ja kurz bei dem punkt noch mal
bleiben was kann man was kann man
dagegen tun ist es jetzt dann doch
wieder nur die politik oder ist werden
noch gefragt sind zweierlei gefragt es
ist erstens die politik gefragt die auf
die warnsignale der wissenschaft der
experten eigentlich schon länger hören
sollte das sehen wir aber also ein
weltweites phänomen dass die politik da
sehr hinterher hinkt es ist aber noch
folgendes zu beachten bei der ganzen
problematik dass die behörden die
regierung stellen die ministerien die
einschlägigen verantwortlichen
sektoralen behörden im grunde genommen
nicht alles das tun können um auf den
großen sandflächen die hier von
klimawandel und von sozioökonomischen
veränderungen betroffen sind alles nun
sozusagen proaktiv zu richten und in der
prävention flächenmäßig das durchführen
zu können
das ist aufgabe auch der
zivilgesellschaft und vor allen dingen
der landbesitzer der waldbesitzer der
der landwirte der beide betriebe aber
auch dass tourismussektor dafür zu
sorgen dass irland
egal welche land nutzungsform das ist er
so bewirtschaftet wird das eben und hier
komme ich wieder zu diesem begriff dem
feuer das brennmaterial entzogen wird
das sehr intensiv bewirtschaftet wird
gepflegt wird und hier ergeben sich im
übrigen auch neue möglichkeiten die
nachwachsenden pflanzlichen biomasse
sozusagen als ein neuer erneuerbare
energiequelle zu erschließen und das
sind alles dinge die sind nicht so ganz
einfach wie zum beispiel der ruf nach
dem kauf von flugzeugen oder
feuerwehrautos
damit ist es nicht getan mit dem versuch
die feuer zu löschen
läuft man im grunde genommen überall in
den regionen hinter den problemen her
und was jetzt eigentlich angeraten ist
das ist sich vor diese entwicklung zu
stellen und sich zu fragen wie können
wir durch maßnahmen der prävention und
der landbewirtschaftung sozusagen unsere
kultur und naturlandschaften und die
menschen die darin leben resümierte und
widerstandsfähiger gegen feuer machen
und das aufbrechen gut 100 jahre und
jahrzehnte ja genau dazu seien auch
frage herr goll damals zum beispiel hier
von lord extras ist er eben ja wie
youtube fragt wie man solche brände in
zukunft verhindern kann
präventionsmöglichkeiten sie haben
gerade von resilienz gesprochen und auch
teenie m fragt wie youtube wie schnell
man auf verbrannte erde wieder
vegetation überhaupt entstehen lassen
kann
und inwiefern gutes force
beziehungsweise waldmanagement eine
ausbreitung von so großen bränden
verhindern kann
naja gutes landmanagement gutes forst
und wald management kann das natürlich
und es ist ja so dass die natur
normalerweise sich nach dem feuer
durchaus regeneriert wenn wir aber das
problem haben dass wir einmal diese
starken und sehr intensiven brände haben
wie im moment und jetzt gleichzeitig die
zukunft bedingt durch den klimawandel
uns beschert dass das land doch mehr
austrocknet weil diese lang anhaltenden
dürreperioden einfach sich
aneinanderreihen
dann ist zu befürchten dass sich zum
beispiel der wald nicht mehr in der form
regenerieren kann wie das früher der
fall war und diese frage der resilienz
die einführung zum beispiel von
gezielter kontrollierter beweidung der
kulturlandschaft aber durchaus auch in
der gemengelage mit dem wald das sind
dinge die in einigen ländern südeuropas
vorzugsweise und beispielsweise in
portugal
und in spanien jetzt wieder eingeführt
werden das heißt die beweidung durch
ziegen schafe und durch kühle kann dazu
führen dass eben hier dem land wie
gesagt das brennmaterial gezielt und
kontrolliert entzogen wird und
gleichzeitig auch tierische produktion
wieder in gang gebracht wird
das ist im grunde genommen eine win win
situation die sich hier entwickeln kann
man muss es nur tun oder tun wollen 1
kommentar will ich zumindest an dieser
stelle auf jeden fall vorlesen weil das
gehört zur wahrheit dazu ronald schluss
schreibt via facebook das natürlich auch
brandstiftung als ursache zu benennen
ist dass es sicher auch ein faktor der
mit hineinspielt aber er allein erklärt
natürlich nicht das was wir gerade
weltweit erleben
abschließend herr goldmann aus ihrer
sicht der sie das global beobachten wie
viel sorge müssen wir uns machen wie
viele chancen haben wir noch etwas daran
zu ändern oder an was müssen wir uns
einfach auch so weit ist die ehrlichkeit
mit uns meint noch gewöhnen
in der fachwelt spricht man über das
motto leben mit feuer
ja wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen mit
feuer zu leben genau wie wir uns
vielleicht daran gewöhnen müssen dass
wir mit starkwinden siehe auch hier bei
uns in deutschland oder mit extremen
niederschlägen und fluten leben können
müssen wir können uns in zum thema feuer
aber wirklich darauf einstellen und das
was die menschen was den menschen sorgen
bereitet das müssen wir in die politik
hinein transportiert die politik muss
langfristige auch nachhaltiger denken
und wir können diese probleme der
veränderung unserer landschaft und der
der veränderung in einer richtung einer
höheren brennbarkeit und eines höheren
risikos das kann man nicht kurzfristig
lösen dazu brauchen wir sehr lange
geplante und anhaltende programme und
vor allen dingen ein neues bewusstsein
über die wertigkeit des ländlichen raums
der ja im grunde genommen vernachlässigt
worden ist in vielen region
der welt und dem wir eigentlich ein eine
neue rolle zuweisen müssen
und das kann durchaus erfordern dass
solche dinge subventioniert werden
müssen und auch so funktioniert werden
können im interesse der gesellschaft
professor johann georg goldammer
danke für diese information und für
diesen appell und danke dass sich zeit
genommen haben schon genannt ich danke
ihnen schön genommen
das war heute live für heute es gibt
wettervorhersagen die sagen am
wochenende könnte es etwas kühler werden
man redet von zwei grad die vielleicht
in der türkei und griechenland
runtergehen dann ist es immer noch viel
zu heiß und vor allem wir haben vorhin
schon mal gehört sind winter angekündigt
die werden die feuer die es dort gibt
noch weiter anfachen
auch daran werden wir uns gewöhnen
müssen in den nächsten tagen das thema
bleibt aktuell
ich danke euch für euer interesse und
fürs mitmachen und sage bis zum nächsten
mal tschüss und gute nacht
[Musik]